all right so we do allegations of sexual
misconduct now swirling around US Senate
candidate judge Roy Moore the left and
the liberal media they're finally
finally starting to re-examine what is
their deplorable defense over the years
Bill Clinton's long history of
disturbing sexual abuse allegations it
has taken almost 30 years for the left
the liberal destroy Trump media to
finally start admitting Bill Clinton
targeted women for decades with criminal
impunity take a look at this headline
from a liberal publication a little late
the Atlantic Bill Clinton a reckoning
feminists saved the 42nd president of
the United States in the 1990s they were
on the wrong side of history is it
finally time to make things right
yes it's beyond time and then there's
this op-ed from the New York Times that
has a headline quote I believe Juanita
but that's not all
members of the mainstream media they're
even starting to realize that what Bill
Clinton did was beyond disgraceful his
conduct should never ever ever have been
defended in the first place what do you
see some of the some of the tape we have
for you tonight
look at this tweet give him credit Chris
Hayes over at MSNBC as gross and cynical
and hypocritical as the writes well what
about Bill Clinton stuff is it's also
true Democrats and the center-left are
overdue for a real reckoning with the
allegations against him take a look at
what CNN's Jake Tapper had to say watch
this the accusers of Bill Clinton back
in the 90s were never given the credence
and treated with the same respect that
these women are being treated and I
think that there is something to be said
about how society has evolved since then
but in addition it's hard not to look
back at that period and think you know
what the media treated those poor
there's women poorly now some of the
media are coming to terms with what they
did and what they said and how they
covered it all up because what they did
the things they did to protect Bill
Clinton and discredit at a high level
his accusers is beyond indefensible it
is shameful let me explain you're not
gonna see this anywhere else on
television back in 1992 during the
presidential primaries remember the name
Jennifer flower
she went public she revealed she had a
12-year affair with Bill Clinton she
even released tape phone conversations
to deal with the allegation one of the
Clinton to campaign do they set up a war
room it sprung into action their job to
smear and discredit Jennifer flowers and
Bill and Hillary then they go on 60
minutes why deny the charges and what
did they do they attack gennifer flowers
character what's this
she's a legend and is described in some
detail in a supermarket tabloid which
she calls a 12-year affair with you that
allegation is false when this woman
first got caught up in these charges I
felt as I felt about all of these women
that you know they've just been minding
their own business and they got hit by
meteors and there was no fault of their
own we reached out to them I met with
two of them to reassure them they were
friends of ours I felt terrible about
what was happening to them you know Bill
talked to this woman every time she
called distraught saying her life was
gonna be ruined and you know he'd get
off the phone and tell me that she said
sort of wacky things which we thought
were attributable to the fact that she
was terrified I'm assuming from your
answer that you're categorically denying
that she ever had an affair with
Jennifer flowers I've said that before
and so was she
I've said that before and so is she they
were lying and because he later had to
admit during a deposition he finally
admitted during the Monica Lewinsky case
that he did in fact have that sexual
encounter with Jennifer flowers and then
there's Hillary Clinton that was only
the beginning of her attempts to smear
her husband's accusers to further attack
flowers Hillary Clinton told Vanity Fair
watch says well if we've been in in
front of a jury I'd say miss flowers
isn't it true you were asked by the AAP
in June of 1990 and you said no were you
asked by the Arkansas Democrat you said
known I mean I would crucify her really
Hillary crucify her and it gets worse
in his book about Hillary called
Bernstein of all people wrote that
Clinton referred to Jennifer flowers as
quote
trailer trash and that clinton undertook
a quote aggressive campaign to go after
flowers years later i did interview
jennifer flowers where she described her
affair with bill clinton and how she
feared for her safety watch this I
regret very much that I have had to go
through in the country has had to go
through what it has gone through in the
last several years there were times when
he wanted to be intimate when Hillary
would be close by and I wouldn't because
I was more concerned with the
circumstances I personally feel that if
I had not become public when I did even
though I had not planned it that I
wouldn't be sitting here talking with
you now I think something would have
happened to me I think most of the women
yeah that had been involved with Bill
Clinton have told of situations where
they were threatened my home was entered
three times in ransacked yeah that was a
horrible failing that was you know that
was pretty darn close my mother received
a fret a threatening phone call that
said your daughter would be better off
dead so there were there were a lot of
things that happened over the course of
this time that caused me will be very
concerned here mice and she was smeared
for years and she had told the truth
then there's Paul Jones she accused Bill
Clinton of confronting her in a hotel
room and dropping his pants and exposing
himself and worse watch this we did some
small talk and then he started kind of
getting a little comfortable and trying
to he said that he loved the way my hair
flow down my back of my clothes and he
liked my curves then he leaned up and he
pulled me up towards him and he was just
gonna try to kiss on me and so then I
tried to distract him again I was trying
to and I thought what am i doing my mind
is racing so well I may need to be going
or something and they say you know he
pulled down his he said and pulled pull
down his pants his whole everything and
he was exposed and I said I'm not that
kind of girl and I need to be getting
back to my to my desk and she said that
many times prior in 1998 Bill Clinton
ended up paying Paul Jones eight hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in
out-of-court settlement for her to drop
her sexual harassment charges
against him and in a related case Bill
Clinton actually lost his license to
practice law in Arkansas for five years
no not many people in the media report
that and according to the New York Times
CNN and many other outlets longtime
Clinton ally James Carville said this
about Paula Jones quote if you drag a
hundred-dollar bill through a trailer
park you never know what you'll find
oh he worked at fake news CNN Paul Jones
later said that there was no way that
Hillary did not know that her husband
was abusing women next we got former
White House intern Monica Lewinsky Bill
Clinton infamously lied about having a
sexual relationship with Lewinsky
remember this I want you to listen to me
I'm going to say this again I did not
have sexual relations with that woman
miss Lewinsky indeed I did have a
relationship with Miss Lewinsky that was
not appropriate in fact it was wrong now
just like the other accusers Hillary had
a less than flattering nickname for
Monica Lewinsky according to a journal
entry that was made public Hillary's
friend Diane Blair described Hillary's
reaction to little Winsky scandalous
quote well she says to his credit that
he tried to break it off tried to pull
away tried to manage someone who was
clearly a narcissistic loony tune but it
was beyond control in an interview with
Diane Sawyer in 2014 Hillary Clinton was
given a chance to deny that she ever
said that about Monica Lewinsky and
Clinton well interestingly design that's
decided to decline a comment watch this
okay sorry it didn't show up now next is
Kathleen Willey I've interviewed her
many times she's a former volunteer
White House aide and accused Bill
Clinton of sexual misconduct in 1993 I
have interviewed Kathleen Willey many
times about this encounter this now goes
gets worse and worse watch this no woman
should be subjected to it it was an
assault he assaulted you yes he and he
touched grabbed fondled and kissed you
asked against your wife
and it's an allegation that is not made
by one woman it's made by multiple of us
now kathleen willey would later slam
Hillary Clinton for enabling her
husband's behavior and finally there's
the most serious the most disturbing
allegation against Bill Clinton
according to Juanita Broderick Bill
Clinton raped her in 1978 when he was
the Attorney General of the state of
Arkansas take a look at this you
described the scene where he was biting
on your lip and then when it was all
over he was leaving said you better put
some ice on that
yeah and casually put on his sunglasses
and walked out the door and I've told my
friend who came back and found me that I
was sitting there crying and so upset at
the time and I felt like somebody that
the next person would be somebody coming
through the door to get rid of the body
that's just about how I had absolutely
couldn't believe what had happened to me
you begged him to stop yes during that
same interview Juanita Broderick explain
why she was fearful to come forward to
tell her story watch this people say
what you waited 20 years mm-hmm do you
regret waiting and why did you wait no I
don't regret waiting because I don't
think it would have been received any
better at that time then it than it is
now I don't think it's anything anybody
wants to hear that the Attorney General
of the state of Arkansas did something
like this no one wanted to hear that and
it was my word against his why did you
originally deny it considering this was
a legal matter did you see what happened
to Jennifer flowers did you see what was
happening to Paula Jones my alligator
yes
no not afraid I just I just knew what
would happen now you just heard Bill
Clinton's accusers in their own words
described in graphic detail what they
say happened to them now despite all of
that the Democrats the liberal destroy
Trump meat
the mainstream media they didn't believe
them they'd attack them they discredited
these women and Hillary Clinton
well she chopped it all up to some
bizarre vast right-wing conspiracy
remember this the great story here for
anybody willing to find it and write
about it and explain it is this vast
right-wing conspiracy that has been
conspiring against my husband since the
day he announced for president now this
tells you everything you need to know
about how Hillary Clinton sees these
victims it's part of a part of a much
larger pattern that we've seen over
decades
for example Clinton's 1992 presidential
campaign remember they coined the term
bimbo eruptions to describe women who
came forward and there were many many
more and George Stephanopoulos he wrote
in his memoir that in 1991 Hillary
Clinton said quote we have to destroy
her when destroying one of Clinton's
accusers now we did reach out to the
Clintons for comment about all of this
of course they never got back to us
that's not surprising considering
everything that they did everything that
Democrats in the media enabled and
covered up almost thirty years
the Clintons over these years have been
given a free pass by their political
party and their friends and their allies
in the news media you know the ones they
colluded with in the last campaign and
up until just a few days ago
the media and Democrats viciously
attacking Bill Clinton's accusers here's
what they said about Clinton's accusers
just last year in the 2016 election
watch this a trio of women who say Bill
Clinton made unwanted sexual advances in
the 80s and 90s mister Clinton denies it
two of the cases were plagued by factual
discrepancies when it was Bill Clinton's
problem almost in the moment Republicans
tried to make it an issue and it didn't
work so why is it gonna work 20 years
later with his wife I just don't see it
and the issue of Bill Clinton's past is
that is that fair game and it would be
as he were running for president but he
isn't Hillary Clinton is running for
I would like to apologize to those
tramps that have slept with my husband
maybe she could have said that way
tramps that slept with my husband now
while it's nice to see that some of the
pressure finally nearly 30 years later
coming around to acknowledge clinton's
actions we have to ask what took you so
long
where were you when these accusers were
coming forward
why did you trash and discredit these
women on a regular basis and I want to
tell you another thing I like the rest
of the abusively biased news media in
this country I did go down take this
seriously sat down with them let them
tell their stories before I made a
decision in these cases you know what
why couldn't the press do the same thing
here's why the media has protected
Democrats people like Clinton by
enabling their abusive and predatory
behavior for decades and guess what
countless women suffered as a result so
this is important as a history lesson we
are you know here tonight where all the
apologies to those women the Clinton
accusers attacked by the campaign by
that war room George Stephanopoulos
worked in the war room James Carville
smeared by Hillary Clinton discredited
by the mainstream media isn't it about
time they all had their day of reckoning
my answer to judge Morris coming up
later